What if you could release a feature to different
groups of users without deployment? Is there a way
to effectively test features in production, and
immediately roll them back if needed? Hi, my name
is Dilan Orrino with IBM Cloud. I'll be answering
those questions by discussing feature flags,
or sometimes referred to as feature toggle,
or switches. Feature flags are conditions
that encompass feature code that allow you to
flip them on and off at will. Okay, let's use
an example. Let's say we've got an ice cream shop
franchise that's looking to expand to a new city
and we've got a banner that we want to display
on our website. We'll call this open banner.
We only want to display this banner to users that
are nearby our new ice cream shop we can do this
by using feature flags. There's a
couple benefits to using feature flags.
Number one is we can actually turn
these on or off without deployment.
Number two is we can actually
test directly in production.
And number three we can segment our
users based on different attributes.
Okay, there's a couple ways you can do this
one way is by using properties in JSON files
or config maps. There's a better way however
by using a feature flag service. There's a
couple benefits to using a feature flag service.
Number one is you can have essentially managed
place
for your features, or excuse me your feature
flags. Number two is you can turn these on and off
without modifying
your properties in your future, in your
apps or web pages. And number three is you
get audit and usage data. It's harder to get
the audit and usage data by using JSON files.
Okay, so now let's go back to our
example we've got our open banner
feature and now let's wrap it
with some feature flag code.
And so here's an example, kind of pseudo
code, that you can use if store open
is enabled.
Then we're going to show open banner
so this pseudocode represents our feature code
and the flag that potentially could encompass it.
Now let's actually put this in production
and make it show showcase to some users. So
now that we've got our feature in production
it's not usable to any users right now
this is an idea typically displayed with feature
flags called dark launch. Dark launch is when a
feature is in production but not visible to any
or all users or any or some users, excuse me.
Now we want to introduce the idea of segments.
So we've already said that we only want
a certain number of people to view this,
people who are nearby our new shop. This will be
our segment A, and a segment is simply users or
groups of users that have attributes tied to them.
So this first one might have current location,
and zip code.
Attributes, this allows users who
are either currently in the location
or have already stipulated that they live nearby
to view this feature, but before we do that
we want to test the feature out on our
own employees. So we would have segment B
of our testers because we want them to be our
employees the attribute might be email ID.
Now we can effectively test our feature
in production by flipping this toggle on.
So now this feature is on for our testers,
and say maybe something went wrong so we're
actually going to flip it off fix it, and
then we'll turn it back on for segment B
once we're satisfied that everything is
working well. Then we can flip this on
for our segment A now all this is done without
a deployment because our feature is already in
production. All we're doing is making it
visible or not visible to certain users
once it is in production. We can actually
add a little bit of automation to this
with our testers, we did it manually, we flipped
it on and off manually, but with feature flags we
can actually add a time element. So let's say we
only want this to be viewable for three weeks, two
weeks before grand opening, one week after grand
opening of our new shop. This will be flipped on
and then automatically turned off or not visible
for this segment of users after three weeks.
Okay, so now we're getting really good at using
feature flags so our feature flags are potentially
starting to stack up we might have a couple apps
and a couple websites with a couple different
types of features that are flagged. So we've got
maybe app one here, app two, and say a web page.
With a feature flagging service we can actually
group these in collections so that we're a little
bit more organized with which feature flags are
tied to, which apps are web pages. So now today
we've learned about returning feature flags on
and off without deployment testing directly in
production, and then segmenting those features
based on the user attributes. Thank you for
watching. If you have questions, please drop us
a line below. If you want to see more videos like
this in the future, please like and subscribe.
And don't forget, you can grow your skills and
earn badges with IBM CloudLabs, which are free
browser-based interactive kubernetes labs.